Transcription: Diana Simões
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Le monde est étrange.
Le monde est vraiment étrange.
Regardez, ici même, en ce moment,
nous sommes pris entre deux infinis,
coincés entre l’infiniment grand
et l’infiniment petit.
L’infiniment petit est, bien sûr,
partout autour de nous.
Nous sommes nous-mêmes
faits de milliards d’atomes,
qui répondent aux lois étranges
de la physique quantique.
La physique quantique.
Elle m’a appris l’impensable.
La réalité n’est pas celle
que nous percevons.
Prenons cette orange, par exemple.
Ou l’orange que vous avez
peut-être dans les mains en ce moment.
Eh bien, ces oranges n’existent pas
telles que nous pensons qu’elles existent.
Oui, moi aussi,
ça m’a perturbé cette idée-là.
Et je vais vous expliquer comment,
derrière le rideau de notre quotidien,
se cache une grande machinerie quantique,
qui agit en coulisses
et crée notre réalité.
Je vous propose une petite visite
dans ces coulisses.
Prenons donc notre orange
et, si elle n’existe pas,
cela veut dire déjà que sa couleur
n’est pas censée exister.
Pourtant, la couleur a l’air
d’être un caractère objectif
de la réalité extérieure.
Grâce à nos yeux, n’est-ce pas,
nous pouvons voir cette réalité extérieure
tel qu’elle se montre à nous,
c’est-à-dire montrant
un fruit de couleur orange.
N’est-ce pas ?
Eh bien, non.
Ça ne fonctionne pas du tout comme ça,
car les couleurs sont une illusion.
Les couleurs, ça n'existe pas.
Alors, qu’est-ce qui existe ?
Ce qui existe,
ce sont des ondes, de la lumière,
de l’énergie, du rayonnement.
Autant de termes qui désignent
un même phénomène :
c’est la force électromagnétique,
l’une des quatre forces de l’univers.
Une onde électromagnétique
est portée par un flux de photons.
Les photons sont les particules
élémentaires de la lumière,
qui filent à 300 000 km à la seconde.
Alors concrètement,
comment ça fonctionne ?
Orange.
L’onde électromagnétique
va venir rebondir sur ce fruit
et puis parvenir à mes yeux.
Cette onde va être interprétée,
encodée par mon cerveau,
par un processus biochimique,
électro-biochimique, extrêmement complexe.
Et puis là, mon cerveau va décider
que cette onde-là,
c’est la couleur orange.
La couleur n’est rien d’autre
qu’une création issue
du câblage de mon cortex.
Et comme nous sommes tous
plus ou moins câblés de la même manière,
eh bien, nous allons tous
décider que cette onde,
c’est ce que nous appelons
la couleur orange.
Mais certaines personnes
sont câblées un peu différemment,
comme les daltoniens, par exemple.
Et un daltonien va interpréter
cette onde de cette manière-là.
C’est-à-dire que, pour lui,
l’orange, la couleur orange, c’est ça.
Et si nous étions tous daltoniens ?
Eh bien, la tenue rouge du Père Noël
ressemblerait à ceci.
Et ça nous paraîtrait absolument normal.
Tout ça parce que le rouge, le vert,
le bleu, aucune couleur n'existe.
Ce sont des images mentales,
des créations issues de notre cerveau.
Reprenons…
notre orange
et allons un petit peu plus loin.
Si nous la comprimons
un petit peu entre nos doigts,
nous avons l’impression
que cette orange est pleine de matière.
N’est-ce pas ? Elle est pleine de matière.
Eh non.
Elle n’est pas non plus pleine de matière,
dans l’infiniment petit,
cette orange est vide,
essentiellement vide.
Alors, qu’est-ce qu’il y a
à l’intérieur de cette orange ?
Évidemment, il y a des milliards
et des milliards d’atomes
et ces milliards d’atomes
sont faits à 99,99% de vide.
Eh oui !
Imaginons que le volume entier
de cette salle représente
le volume d’un seul atome de cette orange.
Nous sommes dans un atome.
Alors, qu’allons-nous y trouver ?
Nous allons y trouver surtout
un noyau atomique.
Et ce noyau, où est-il ?
Oui, il est là.
Si je le retrouve.
Il est là le noyau atomique.
Si le volume de cette salle
représente le volume d’un atome,
son noyau a la taille d’un petit pois.
Toute la masse,
ou quasiment toute la masse,
toute la matière contenue
dans cet atome tient là-dedans.
Le reste, il est vide.
Vide… il y a quand même quelque chose,
et ce quelque chose,
ce sont des ondes électromagnétiques.
Eh oui, encore elles, elles sont là.
99,99% du volume d’un atome
est occupé par des ondes
électromagnétiques.
Il y a quand même des tout petits grains
de matière encore dans ce volume atomique.
Ces petits grains de matière,
ce sont les électrons.
Il y en a très peu,
quelques unités,
quelques dizaines au plus.
On peut les imaginer ici
comme de tout petits moucherons
qui seraient en train de voler,
d’orbiter très, très vite
dans ce grand volume.
Et, comme nous sommes dans un atome,
et pour les besoins de la démonstration,
je vais attraper un de ces électrons.
Attention, cascade !
Celui-là.
Voilà.
On va dire que c'est un électron.
Il vous convient celui-là ?
Oui ? Bon.
On va le garder de toute façon.
Donc, cet électron,
il a une particularité.
Il a une charge électrique déjà,
et cette charge électrique est négative.
Alors, c’est important,
parce qu’il faut imaginer
qu’à côté de l’atome
dans lequel nous nous trouvons ici,
il y a d’autres atomes partout à côté,
et ces atomes contiennent eux aussi
des électrons de charge
électrique négative.
Négatif contre négatif,
ça se repousse
comme deux aimants se repoussent.
Mais en quoi cela nous concerne-t-il ?
Orange.
Lorsque je touche
cette orange avec mon doigt,
ce sont les électrons de charge
négative des atomes de mon doigt
qui repoussent
les électrons de charge négative
des atomes de cette orange,
et inversement.
Le toucher et la sensation de solidité
n'existent pas réellement.
Ce qui existe,
c’est de la répulsion électromagnétique.
Idem pour les sièges
sur lesquels vous êtes assis.
En réalité, vous ne les touchez pas.
Vous êtes en sustentation
électromagnétique au-dessus d’eux.
Eh oui !
Donc, résumons.
Dans l’infiniment petit,
nous sommes électromagnétiques
et vides à 99,99%.
Nous nageons littéralement
dans un brouillard électromagnétique.
Ce brouillard, les physiciens
l’appellent aussi des champs quantiques.
Alors, très rapidement,
un champ quantique -
les électrons, les photons,
dont je viens de vous parler,
et d’ailleurs toutes
les autres particules,
sont, par nature, dans un état
qu’on appelle indéterminé ou incertain,
c’est-à-dire qui sont, à la fois,
partout et nulle part, en même temps,
dans un grand champ quantique,
une grande onde qui s’étend
dans l’ensemble de l’univers.
Retenons ici simplement cette idée
de brouillard électromagnétique.
Et, dans ce brouillard électromagnétique,
nous avons vu que le toucher
et la vision sont électromagnétiques.
Mais, en réalité, toutes nos perceptions,
absolument toutes,
sont à la base électromagnétiques.
C’est difficile à croire
et, pourtant, c’est vrai.
Il y a quelques années,
un scientifique américain a imaginé
une expérience de pensée
qui illustre ce propos.
Vous rentrez chez vous ce soir,
après cette présentation,
et, malheureusement, en chemin,
un savant fou vous kidnappe.
C'est lui.
Et ce savant fou vous emmène
dans son laboratoire
et il va, comme vous le voyez,
prélever votre cerveau.
Il va brancher votre cerveau
à un appareillage ultra sophistiqué,
capable de reproduire à la perfection
tous vos stimuli sensoriels.
Et, comme tous ces stimuli sensoriels
sont électromagnétiques,
et qu’ils sont interprétés
par votre cerveau,
vous ne feriez pas la différence.
Votre cerveau serait dans cette cuve,
mais vous auriez l’impression
de vivre absolument normalement.
Eh oui, à l’échelle de l’infiniment petit,
tout n’est que brume, quantique,
brouillard électromagnétique.
Non.
Tout.
Mais non, c'est pas tout en fait.
Souvenez-vous, il reste quelque chose.
Notre noyau, notre petit pois.
Notre noyau atomique, souvenez-vous.
Voici enfin quelque chose
de rassurant, de palpable.
Ce noyau rassemble l'essentiel
de la matière, de la masse.
C'est un concentré de matière.
Ou est-ce vraiment
un concentré de matière ?
Si je vous pose la question maintenant,
vous devez vous douter
que la réponse est peut-être
« non, ce n’est pas
un concentré de matière ».
Et, effectivement, ça ne l’est pas.
Pas du tout, pas du tout,
dans le sens où on l’entend.
Alors, qu’est-ce qu’il y a
dans ce noyau atomique ?
Dans ce noyau atomique,
il y a trois quarks dans un proton.
Il s’agit d’un atome d’hydrogène,
le plus simple qui existe.
Ces trois quarks, ce sont
des particules élémentaires de matière
et ils sont tenus par une force,
qu’on appelle les gluons.
Les bien nommés, les gluons.
Donc, ces trois quarks sont tenus
ensemble par des gluons.
Et c’est tout ce qu’il y a
dans ce noyau atomique.
Et c’est bien le problème,
parce que nos trois quarks ne tiennent
que pour 1% de la masse totale
de ce noyau atomique.
Où sont donc les 99% restants ?
Les 99% restants de la masse
de nos oranges,
de vos masses,
de la masse de tout
ce qui existe d’ailleurs ?
Eh bien, tenez vous bien,
cette masse provient
de l’énergie des gluons,
cette colle qui tient
ensemble nos trois quarks.
Oui, de l'énergie.
Parce que, depuis Einstein
et sa fameuse équation E=MC2,
nous savons que l’énergie peut
se transformer en masse,
et la masse en énergie,
les deux sont équivalents.
Ok, donc notre masse provient
de l'énergie de gluons.
C'est déjà bizarre, mais il y a pire.
Cette énergie provient
du vide, de nulle part, du néant.
Bon.
Prenons un espace et nous le vidons
de tout ce qu’il contient.
Nous enlevons…
la matière, toute substance,
toute particule qui peut y exister.
Une fois que nous avons tout enlevé,
il reste toujours quelque chose,
et, ce quelque chose,
ce sont des champs quantiques.
Ces champs quantiques peuvent
faire apparaître de l’énergie
à partir de rien du tout, du vide.
Démonstration.
Je reprends mon petit pois,
mon noyau atomique,
et nous allons faire apparaître ici
de l’énergie à partir du vide quantique.
Attention, vous êtes prêts ?
Alors, n’ayez pas trop d’attentes
quant à l’aspect spectaculaire
de ces démonstrations.
Vos attentes sont modestes ?
C’est très bien, vous allez voir.
Attention, par exemple,
l’énergie va apparaître ici,
à partir du vide.
Pouf !
Une fluctuation d’énergie
est apparue à partir du vide.
Cette fluctuation va venir
vers mon noyau atomique,
va se transformer en masse,
partiellement, grâce à E=MC2,
et puis va repartir
vers le vide quantique.
Ça dure environ
10 puissance moins 21 secondes.
et ça va continuer.
C’est un ballet incessant de ces…
fluctuations de particules virtuelles,
dont l’énergie va créer
le 99% de la masse
de ce noyau atomique.
Et le 1% restant ?
Le 1% restant, c’est la masse même
de nos trois quarks.
Eh bien, elle vient, elle aussi,
d’un champ du vide, d’un champ quantique,
un autre : le champ de Higgs,
et son fameux boson de Higgs,
dont vous avez sans doute entendu parler.
Donc l’arithmétique est simple :
99% plus 1% égale 100%.
100% de notre masse
provient du vide quantique,
100% de la masse de nos oranges,
de la masse de tout ce qui existe.
Donc du vide quantique, ça veut dire,
de l’énergie de particules virtuelles,
virtuelles parce qu’elles
ne sont pas censées exister,
qui surgissent du vide,
qui n’est pas vide.
Je vous l’ai dit en préambule,
le monde est étrange.
La masse, l’énergie et la matière
ne sont pas ce que nous en percevons.
Et c'est valable aussi d'ailleurs
pour l'espace et le temps.
L’espace-temps.
Mais ceci concerne plutôt
l’infiniment grand,
et c’est une autre histoire
que j’aurais peut-être le plaisir
de vous raconter une autre fois.